- YO, YO, YO, WHAT UP,
WHAT UP, WHAT UP?
WELCOME TO BATTLE RAP,
WHERE WE'RE GONNA BATTLE RAP
EVERY DAY IN THE MONTH OF
FEBRUARY, Y'ALL.
YO, I'M YOUR HOST,
BIG PEEP-PAROO!
all: R-R-R-ROO!
- THAT'S RIGHT, THAT'S RIGHT,
THAT'S RIGHT, THAT'S RIGHT.
TO MY LEFT, WE GOT THE CHAMPION.
YO, INTRODUCE, SON!
- YEAH, WHAT'S HAPPENIN'?
THIS YOUR BOY, RHINO D,
AND I'M ABOUT TO FRONTHAND...
BACKHAND HIS ASS
OFF THE MIC!
- THAT'S RIGHT, THAT'S RIGHT,
THAT'S RIGHT.
AND ON MY RIGHT,
WE GOT THE CHALLENGER.
INTRODUCE YOURSELF, PLAYA.
- YEAH, WHAT'S UP, MAN?
I'M DILLER KILLER,
IN THE HOUSE.
100 USDA PURE MEAT.
NO FILLER RIGHT HERE, DAWG.
- HOO! HOO! [barks]
- OKAY, OKAY.
YO, DILLER LOST THE TOSS,
SO YOU GO FIRST.
OKAY, GENTLEMEN,
BATTLE RAP!
- ALL RIGHT, YEAH.
NOW, HERE WE GO.
YOU'RE SHOOK, SON.
I'M GONNA EAT YOU FOR BREAKFAST.
'CAUSE I'M A COOK, SON.
- HA HA!
I STOLE A COP-A-FEEL
FROM YOUR GIRL'S BREASTESES!
- YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
- [high-pitched growling]
- WAIT A MINUTE.
GET BACK.
- [growling continues]
- HE DON'T EVEN KNOW, MAN.
HEY, LISTEN, MAN.
YOU CAN'T EVEN WIN
THIS 100-YARD DASH,
BUT LET ME ASK YOU
A QUESTION.
WHAT DO THEY CALL THAT,
A MOUSTACHE?
all: OHH...
- [growling]
AAAAH!
AAH!
- NO, MAN, SEE--
RELAX, MAN. HEY, I NEED YOU
TO RELAX A LITTLE BIT.
- [growling]
- TAKE IT DOWN
A LITTLE BIT.
- AHHHHHH...
- WHAT THE [bleep] YOU DOIN'?
I'M TELLING YOU, TAKE--CAN YOU
TAKE IT DOWN A LITTLE BIT, MAN?
- [growls quieter]
- COME ON, WHAT ARE YOU,
A HORSE? LIKE...
- AAAAH!
- THAT'S THE LAST ONE.
YO, WHAT'S UP, DAWG?
YOU KNOW, MY [bleep] IS RICH.
I'M SWIMMIN' IN SIMOLEONS.
WHAT AM I SUPPOSED TO DO WITH
THIS MINIATURE BLACK NAPOLEON?
- [growling]
- YEAH, ALL RIGHT.
YO! HEY, MAN.
HEY, DAWG,
GET YOUR--HEY, HEY!
NOW--COME ON, NOW.
DON'T GET MY EYES WET.
HEY, HEY, GET YOUR BOY--
- WAAAAAAH!
- YO, I'M SORRY.
LOOK AT THAT. LOOK AT THIS.
LOOK AT THIS.
LOOK AT IT. LOOK AT IT.
OH, OH, YEAH.
GO GET IT, NOW.
THAT'S A BOY. OH.
YEAH, MAN! HERE WE GO!
YEAH, MAN, LOOK AT THAT CHAIN
AND THESE FAKE-ASS
TIMBERLANDS.
- AAAAAAHHH...
- OH, MAN!
- I'M SORRY.
NO, YOU'RE OKAY, MAN.
I'M SORRY.
I REALLY APOLOGIZE.
- YO, MAN.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH HIM, MAN?
- HEY, HEY!
REMEMBER--NO, NO, HEY!
- AAAAAAHHH...
AHH AHH!
- WHY ARE YOU DOING ME?
- AAAAAHH!
- WHY WOULD YOU--LISTEN.
- AAAAH!
- NO. NO, NO, NO. COME ON.
- AAAAHH!
- SHH. SHH. SHH.
- ALL RIGHT,
YOU GUYS GOTTA GO, MAN.
- NO, COME ON, MAN.
- NO, MAN.
NO, YOU'RE ALL DONE, MAN.
YOU GOT TO GO.
THAT'S RIGHT, MAN.
YO, WE GOT A CHAMPION STILL.
WE GOT A CHAMPION STILL
RIGHT HERE.
- HEY, WHAT'S HAPPENIN'?
YEAH! THAT'S WHAT'S UP.
THAT'S YOUR BOY--
- AAAAAAHH...
- JUST...GIVE ME THE HAT!
- HEY, MAN--
- GIVE IT UP!
[indistinct shouting]
GIMME THAT [bleep] HAT!
[birds chirping]
- [sustained gibberish]
- LISTEN.
LISTEN--LISTEN, MAN.
I WANT YOU TO LOOK OUT
ON THE LAKE, MAN.
I JUST WANT YOU TO LOOK OUT
AND IMAGINE A PLACE, MAN,
WHERE YOU CAN DO
YOUR THING, MAN.
- HOOOOO...
- WHERE YOU AND I COULD GO
AND DO OUR THING,
BUT NEVER HAVE TO FORFEIT, YEAH!
- YAHH.
- YOU COULD SCREAM AND SHOUT
AND SHOVE PEOPLE
BACK AND FORTH, BUT WE DON'T
NEVER HAVE TO QUIT.
- AAAAH!
- BUT LOOK OUT ON THE LAKE, MAN.
LOOK OUT ON THE LAKE.
NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS, MAN,
I START RAPPIN'.
- HWAH!
- AND MY RHYMES,
THEY START TO FLOW.
AND I'M TURNIN' THE TIDE.
AND NO MATTER WHAT YOU DO,
YOU CAN PUSH AND SHOVE
AND SCREAM, BUT WE'LL NEVER
GET DISQUALIFIED.
- LAA LAA LAA!
AH HA HA HA!
YEAH, YEAH, OOH! HA-HA!
- MAN, FOR GOOD MEASURE, WHILE
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE LAKE,
JUST GIVE ME
ONE MORE GOOD "AAAAHH."
- AAAAH--
[gunshot]